and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review x-men origins Wolverine
my father was the world yes he comes to
take care of you yes he comes across
this Cajun guy called Wolverine his like
we shouldn't be fighting you're right
we'll say that for the first x-men movie
in which case L grow blonde hair never
talking forget who you are in genius so
the army guide releases them you with
all the other mutant powers and his name
is Deadpool also known as
cool so they have a fight on top of the
nuclear power plants and silver box
comes up to Wolverine and says let's be
together forever and ever but she
deities again I worry is like I wish I
could just forget about all of this and
the army guy is like okay don't worry no
memory about who he is and he just walks
off into the sunset knowing nothing
welcome to my life bud waking up in
front of a destroyed power plant with a
radioactive mutant in front of you
that's like every week for me must be
Sundays
this is jittery bunny pilot I just like
to destroy things